[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today I'll show you how to
deploy NGINX Plus in Google
Cloud launcher.
NGINX Plus is a complete
application delivery platform
combining load balancing,
content caching, web server,
security controls,
and monitoring.
In cloud launcher type and NGINX
in the search bar and select
NGINX plus from the results.
Click launch on
Google Cloud Platform.
Select the project where you
want to deploy NGINX Plus
and click continue.
Next configure the name
and other parameters
for a new instance.
Click Deploy.
An instance with the latest
version of NGINX Plus
will deploy.
To learn more about
NGINX configuration
and activate support,
click Getting Started,
and go to NGINX Support.
To get started with NGINX
Plus on cloud launcher,
click on the link
in the comments.
Thanks for watching.